d'abord une question générale à part
cette tribune commune existe-t-il des
démarches pour regrouper les communes
grandes ou petites touchées par le
narcotrafic afin d'échanger notamment
avec les villes guyanaises d'où part une
partie de la drogue consommée dans vos
villes et une question particulière à
Monsieur Piol je sais que la ville de
Grenoble met en place de nombreuses
actions pour lutter contre le
narcotrafic mais Monsieur le Maire en
dehors de l'augmentation des effectifs
de poli ce qu'attendez-vous de l'État
sur la la coopération et des villes de
guyan nous n'avons pas d'échange
spécifique sur des échanges entre la
Guyane et la France nous nous intégrons
au sein de France urbaine c'est donc les
les villes de plus de 100000 habitants
et les intercommunalités de plus de
200000 ou 250000 corrige-moi natthalie
je crois que c'est
250000 donc qui
regroupe une centaine du coup de
d'adhérents entre ville et
intercommunalité nous nous avons une
commission donc notre principe c'est
évidemment la la réflexion
transpartisane et nous avons une
commission qui traite de ces sujets et
qui en tout cas depuis que je suis ma
c'est depuis 10 ans est très
consensuelle sur à la fois le partage du
vécu il est important pour nous de
pouvoir partager notre vécu qui est
parfois un peu lourd en ces domaines
deième partie qu'est-ce qu'on attend de
l'État ben nous
attendrions des critères d'évaluation
sur la la stratégie de lutte contre
le trafic et narcotrafic mais aussi sur
la consommation pour nous ce qui nous
inquiète nous regardons aussi les
questions de santé publique nous voyons
les l'explosion de la consommation nous
voyons celle du cannabis bien sûr qui a
un niveau extrêmement élevé mais
également ces dernières années une
banalisation de de la cocaïne et donc
nous aimerions une une stratégie qui
disent c'est quoi les critères
d'évaluation d'une bonne politique de
lutte contre la drogue en prenant en
compte toute la chaîne des questions de
santé publique aux questions de sécurité
de sécurité liée au trafic de drogue
mais également de la répartition des
moyens entre cette lutte contre la
drogue et le reste des phénomènes de
violence que nous vivons dans la société
et que pour lesquels nous sentons
parfois un manque de moyens euh voilà
nous aimerions nous avons répété
Nathalie apéré disait tout à l'heure une
transparence euh de la part du ministère
sur la répartition des effectifs